13 août 1961
berlin se réveille coupée en deux je fus
réveillé pendant la nuit
alain travaux j'ai regardé par la
fenêtre au pouvoir que se cache un mur
sépare désormais deux mondes
à cette époque berlin et couper en
quatre les secteurs anglais américains
et français à l'ouest la portion
soviétique a list de modes de vie
opposés deux idéologies en lutte l'est
subit un exode massif
et c'est pour garder sa population que
les soviétiques et riche d'un mur berlin
maintenant était coupée en deux sans
fissure du jour au lendemain
des amis sont séparés des familles
brisées de part et d'autre de ce rempart
la fillette à l'ouest la mer à l'est
elles pourraient encore se parler mais
elles ne sont pas seules à quelques
mètres de là il y a une voiture avec des
policiers de l'est alors la mère a peur
de se compromettre et elle s'en va
l'injustice à l'est comme à l'ouest deux
mondes désormais face à face les
escabeaux les échelles les jumelles tout
est bon pour espérer trouver un regard
de l'autre côté il ne reste que les yeux
pour communiquer vous avez de la famille
de l'autre côté des parents mon fils
ma soeur vous l'avez déjà aperçu jamais
elles habitent trop loin les enfants
quelquefois quand ils jouent dans la rue
le mur grandi mois après mois
il dépasse des trois mètres de hauteur
jalonnée de 302 tour de contrôle
surveillé par 2 159 unités de chien de
garde
à l'ouest la foule s'élèvent contre ce
qu'ils ont baptisé le mur de la honte
ces mesures ont suscité une
manifestation de 15 mille jeunes
berlinois de l'ouest qui à la lumière
des torches ont organisé une marche de
protestation contre le mur d'autres en
revanche montre plus de sérénité ils
font confiance aux américains pour le
maintien de la paix à moins qu'il y ait
n'a une certaine lassitude des aléas
géopolitiques dans la capitale je suis
resté pendant toute la guerre je suis
resté attendront la bataille de ballons
et je suis resté lorsque les russes sont
venus
je suis resté debout pendant le blocus
de berlin le mur de berlin s'étend sur
43 km se poursuit en dehors de la ville
111 km au total 28 ans plus tard
ce mur est abattu il en reste
aujourd'hui des centaines de mètres
le souvenir est essentielle d'une ville
un temps des zooms
[Musique]